thank you
[Music]
welcome back to careful boys we're
indeed careful boys what is something
you could never tell your mother about
ever and if she saw this video she would
positively die oh she watches I can't
say anything oh [__] mind is true and
she she called me one day and she goes
you know you shouldn't be talking about
blow jobs there's kids watching your
show but that was about five years ago
maybe if you gave dad blow jobs you'd
still be around
I might I might be the worst person to
ask
because I'm in the Yas Queen phase of my
life yes
Queen anything that I think I can't wait
to [__]
say to her so I could put the cigarette
out in her face
no [__] oh it's like this yeah
he's a strong independent woman all
those
son of a [__] yeah yeah I don't think
you're very coordinated for this yeah
because I scream I spray my thumbs I'm
trying to clap without hurting it you're
gonna clap with every word but it hurts
every word I realized I was hurting wow
you know like what's the antithesis of
Buddhism like what if if you're if
you're Christian right so you become a
devil worshiper to scare your parents
what can you do as a Buddhist to scare
your parents that's a good question and
as a Christian and if your mom's a fake
Buddhist
what's the opposite of Buddhism I that's
what I'm saying Scientology no chaos
Anarchy yeah
I can't believe Buddhist people aren't
even
um like that peaceful it's like very
intense
so I keep hearing when I read Siddhartha
I was like this is [__] chill and
then I met you guys I'm like damn
you know what my mom's prayers in the
morning she wakes up at like four or
some [__] and then she does like 108
Buddhist burpees kind of sounds like you
dude it was a Buddhism yeah legit it's
the religious version of you the food is
Burpee but it's like so you bow how do
you do it for us
[Laughter]
and she does 108 of them and she doesn't
that's a lot two times a day but that's
why your mom's in really good shape
though regular burpees at four in the
morning yeah yeah why are you doing it
that's true this guy's just shuffling
for 20 minutes around you know but he
does it for the Flying Spaghetti Monster
apparently
you know what's the kind of mild thing
that I think she'd be pissed about yeah
is that uh so when I had braces I got
them when I was in eighth grade and I
got them off senior year like I had them
on super six years later six years wait
eighth grade to see about four years oh
four years but I was only supposed to
have them on for two but the um my mom
was like yeah I don't know why it's like
taking forever for your teeth to like
move but the reason was because I I
never wore my rubber band yeah because
you know you're supposed to put the
bands on and I always lied and said I
was doing it but it took way longer my
mom the whole time she'd be the one
driving me to the appointments and she'd
be asking like what's taking so long
like he's he's almost about to graduate
she's the damnest thing he's doing it
all right and they would always ask me
you wear your rubber bands right I'm
like yeah what do you think we ended up
throwing them in the trash are you
really trying to deflect the blame on me
yeah you guys have any secrets you guys
have any secrets or lies that you
haven't fully exposed to your parents
yet that's I mean that's one of them
what a perfect place to do it at right
there's no place I don't think it's that
mild dude I think it's way more serious
than you think braces rubber bands yeah
I think it's way more serious dude you
should consider taking this out I should
probably have a hard time with my mom
tonight before before she's gonna be
like do you know how much money we spend
on that yeah what I'm hyped about is
that there's like 7 000 [__] videos
that I'm in on this channel she'll never
find this one
really my mom is like FBI agent she'll
watch everything you'll be like why did
you say that about that yeah
the JK audience when you say your mom
will never see this then they're just
gonna get sent to her
but I also kind of want her to see you
guys what's yours yeah what's something
big to say well I want to [__] my wife's
butt pretty bad
yeah she should know it yeah whatever
that would like like is that something
that you can't you're not allowed to do
I think that my mom was so sexually
weird growing up that yeah she would
hate to know that
yeah she would hate oh I see yeah but
what's [__] up is that I that Nikki
said that she would do it before we got
married and then now it's been six years
and she hasn't done anything
no I didn't get free numbers
I could have written that clause in as
if it's the only thing I want can you
imagine
you're at court you're like your honor
your honor she promised me sodomy it's
been six years give me that boot did she
at least have it in the vows during the
wedding yeah
you gotta mention it
I feel like your marriage is missing
just that one percent you just needs it
needs anal
y
just double the volume wherever it is
double doubling zero is zero no that's
true yeah I need yeah actually I mean
they can they can't bait and switch you
no that's what I'm saying yeah it's
[__] up that's [__] up
it's completely [__] up yeah it's in
there so having to hold for goodness
in-house back or front I will say it
doesn't feel good to put my dick in a
butt I've done it before not to brag
yeah I have done it before thank you for
saying that but it's about the territory
yeah I have not been in that but yeah
it's like Area 51 like everyone wants to
you're like this is my point I'm just
gonna look for the UFOs last week
let's see what the government's lying
about
I sure hope it
hopefully there's nothing [__] so this
is more about Nikki seeing it than your
mom no no no no no no no my Nikki would
not give a [__] about this have you told
Nikki about your your wishes about my
anal Adventures yeah hey your Christmas
wish yeah what did she say you haven't
forgotten you didn't [__] makes fun
of me that's it I'm such an idiot yeah
so she thinks so she thinks that you're
faking yeah
she holds it she promised this before
you make it Bane switch man but she
knows the thing that the worst thing
about this [__] is she knows that I
don't actually want anal I just want the
territory yeah yeah I think that's all
you need from her is a yes and then you
go I'll take it another day I think most
women don't realize that exactly but
she's such a pain in my ass that like
like I just want to get and get it in
and get it out but then I'd be like a
pain in hers well but yes but then she
she would be so [__] annoying after
because I know it would hurt her and
stuff and then I'd have to [__] deal
with it all night um
she'll bug you the whole night my ass
the other day
she'll be like that man you actually
liked it and then she's addicted now and
she goes I didn't know you just [__]
opened up a whole new portal for me now
you gotta have chocolate covered dick
all day and then now that becomes the
main entrance yeah all day and you're
like can I at least get some [__] yeah
she's all like nope it'll be like I
remember the good old days yeah yeah
what have I done you follow your knees
open Pandora's Box I can't close it I
should have read that story yeah yeah
got too close to the Sun my man once you
go ass you never go back to puss that's
what they usually say cheese
it's so true it doesn't have to run can
we just get that tattoo instead of
Japanese well I'm not part of this video
barquan surely there's something you
can't tell your mom you don't feel
embarrassed nothing's over the line for
you you think I think I've been so
restricted as a kid
like from wearing like forcing me to
wear school uniforms when it wasn't even
required by the school to doing like be
a monk for a day to doing the 48 hours
did you wear a robe did you have to do
so much weird [__] you have to wear
robes when I was doing the monkey thing
to doing like little part in a robe like
doing like a monk for a whole week
I have to do a one where there's like a
whole like vow of silence for seven days
like I've done so much crazy [__] that I
think by the time I rebelled as a
teenager I didn't really give a [__]
anymore it was just like
um what is that word like point of no
return so it's just like yeah this is
ecstasy check it out Mom I'm just
putting my mouth in front of her like
like homies come and just pick me up at
3am I don't give a [__] I think it was
just so I don't give a [__] I had to
like
go out that I think from that point on
that kind of re-established our
relationship in a re-established our
relationship in a way where they're
I don't have to hide anything or
but not in like a good way I feel like
it is kind of a little bit unhealthy
because it's almost at a complete
disregard for her feelings so I feel
like now in my 30s entering 40s I'm
trying to find the way back because I
think it's swung this way then it swung
really hard this way where I don't give
a [__] but then I'm like but she is my
mom so I'm trying to like right go back
in the middle somehow dude inversely I
will say
one of the hardest things for me at
least from all my [__] childhood
animosity and [__] it's really [__]
hard for me to straight up go I love you
mom
really that's [__] hard really so
what about or dad what about the
Christmas all that stuff do you like I
have to find other ways to say it's kind
of like one of these okay that's good
see you later or yeah because they're
the same way with me like awkward hug
and [__] my dad will side hug me when
I'm saying bye and [__] I'm like what is
this what are we doing but it's just
it's [__] weird we didn't plant those
seeds like when was the last time you
told your dad I love you and what did he
respond with
I don't I don't even remember dude I
honestly don't remember last time I said
that I because I'd never say it straight
out I can't I just like freeze up oh so
I gotta find other like [__] Avenues
call them right now do it on the show
for a bit
holy [__] just foreign
never said I love you to each other for
probably like two decades I think wow
that's about right though once maybe a
couple months ago actually last year it
was like one of the first times I was
like I was trying to make an effort to
make a better list for my dad and like
the rest of my family and I was like I
was like all right Dad talk to you later
love you and he goes
all right I'll see you later
Daddy's dude that's the most
because it was so like we usually it
like went through his whole body yeah
yeah he like dropped the phone for a
second oh geez just because they're not
ready for it yeah dude 100 because we
were [__] Millennials these days my
son is gay I think
he's like ew gross what do you think it
is from that generation that they're so
like you think about your grandparent
right I don't know I can't relate
because my I always told my parents I
love them they were always awesome I
would say my dad was not as vocal for
sure but was he vocal with her brother
too no I think my dad was very much like
reserved I think the way they treat
daughters is is it's been okay to say I
love you to your daughter like for like
even you know in traditional families
and stuff it's a little yeah colder but
still not your son though
Sons don't get it dude
I my goal is to make sure taika is like
a tough prepared little dude so like he
lives in a pretty discipline and like I
feel like he he like um I make sure that
he has control challenges yeah but every
day
I always ask him I'm like who's my
favorite person in the whole wide world
he goes me you know so he knows I love
him I told him yes
[Laughter]
[Applause]
yeah but he was like he knows that I
love him and I tell him I love him you
know and um and I'm like that's I wonder
what stopped my dad from expressing
their dads yeah listen to their stories
it's yeah I haven't heard any
kind like well kindness is a different
um I guess it's it's subjective
depending on the era but like how they
were treated by their own
fathers and grandparents and whatever is
different and then like the idea of
childhood like of us playing and [__]
like that that's true that's true and
preserving that that [__] didn't exist
in their generation and above that's
true by the time they're like [__]
five years old they're already taking
care of siblings are working at the
factory yeah everything's obligation
responsibility mentality of this soft
like enjoying life and loving and
sharing and all that like I think they
just don't understand those Concepts you
can work at a factory it doesn't take
that long to say I love you
okay
I know coal miners it takes about three
seconds actually yeah it's a longer
three seconds what's really sad is I I
distinctly remember probably the last
time my Dad tried to like connect with
me was I was like a teenager I was like
14 or 15. and my dad's like uh sat down
next to me and this is already when I'm
in the defiant era when I'm kind of
being a little [__] and he was like hey
um
you know how your mom and your sister
they talk about everything and they you
know they have a nice relationship I was
like yeah so and he's like maybe we
could have kind of it's all nice and I
was like yeah right
yeah whatever nerd wow and then he just
like gave up I never heard him try oh
wow shut him down well he actually tried
though he gave it a really honest shot
and then and then was like yeah you're
right I'm being gay and just like stop
and then we just all we have are like
jokes we only have like roasts and jokes
and that's how that's cool what if one
day he showed up and there was like him
wearing your wardrobe yo yo yo bro yeah
he does that [__] all the time like he
was he would he would do that with like
uh like some of my my cool gear like a
risu shade or like dance [__] that I get
from so he has a sense of humor he wore
hella party rock [__] one time I was
like
yeah he hasn't he's that's how we like
Express like uh our love is like jokes
do you think then there is hope that one
day can get it can get there I think
we're both because it feels warm not
cold we can both read into the messages
enough that we're okay with this
um and I think you have to Progressive
and I think when I do like sometimes
randomly if I do try to get a little
like hey like we were talking like
really recently about how all my friends
from high school their parents are dead
and we were talking about it I'm like
you guys are doing pretty good you're
like my parents are alive yeah they're
like mid 70s and they're pretty healthy
my dad's still working and he's he I was
like yeah I'm glad uh I'm glad you guys
are still here and he was just like okay
until I think
opens the floodgates of unsaid millions
of words that it's too much yeah and you
guys aren't ready for it you can eat the
Shabu yeah yeah yeah yeah let's just
spend time with each other right now we
got one hour this all you can eat
any minute limit idiot stuff your face
that's what I do notice there's so many
like those relationships where there's
so much [__] sweat under the rug that
that is now the new floor right and if
you want to see what's really there
there's a lot you gotta pull out that's
why I think when it's when you're
questioning about like what can you say
that would that I wouldn't want to tell
my mom I don't think I have any bad
secret that would be more jarring than
saying something nice which is crazy
holy [__] dude you're surrounded
Darkness
I think it's only recently that we
started saying like I love you on the
phone at the end of the phone to your
mom yeah it is so [__] weird bro but
she initiated it oh that's cool I think
she did it every single time without
fail for for a couple of years because
she wanted to change the dynamic and I
started I started saying it after like
three four years yeah yeah do you mean
it or you just say it because just
return it just to hang up um no I mean
it I mean it you hang up
bro the best fall asleep talking to each
other
[Laughter]
stop it
I think what changed I think what
changed was um
stupid
I think I think what changed was um her
approach like it wasn't her she was
giving me the time to process rather
than forcing me to be on her same page
um so like she when when she started
acting like oh I'm bothering you I'm
gonna like she was playing hard of
getting [__] like ending the phone calls
early I know you're busy this and that I
don't want to bother you then I started
feeling like
oh [__] like she feels like a burden to
me and I do treat her like a burden
because she was yeah and then it was
like
later on we just started having regular
conversations because you know like that
shift when they stop lecturing you yeah
yeah yeah yeah and have an authentic
conversation yeah and after that I was
like this is what I want is a this is
how we have a relationship and she goes
I know but I've been your mother for how
many years like I gotta tell you what to
do yeah like it bothers me yeah and then
I'm like and then she goes I'm trying to
change that though because I just wanna
I wanna know the real you and she said
have uh watching YouTube have helped her
wow because she's like when I was able
to just watch your YouTube and your
Vlogs and your Instagram and I stalked
the [__] out of you she calls me she she
calls herself my number one stalker
and then she goes like when I saw you
and your element how you really are with
your friends and everything she goes
then I got to love the real you because
she goes what when I was Raising you
she's like I had an expectation that's
deep yeah what my perfect son would be
and she goes I was a uh uh emotionally
unavailable because she goes if you
weren't my ideal then she's like I
neglected you and I was like what the
[__] and she goes yeah so that's why we
don't have the love that I want from you
and then so when she said that I was
like holy [__] you changed and then so
and then I gave her the more time to
like build a relationship so now it's
[__] solid between us it doesn't feel
like oh this [__] [__] calling me I
feel like oh [__] I can't wait to see my
mom whenever that happened that is
happening right now with me and my mom
that's tight just started happening
where she's starting to say sorry she
realized like she was emotionally
unavailable because she'll see the way
that I I play with taika and I'm very
loving and stuff and she's like I just
couldn't like when I was a single parent
like I have to like do all these things
that I'm trying to whatever she was like
that's why I was like my love was so
conditional I knew you were crying and I
knew I was supposed to hug you but you
also [__] up and I don't have time for
that and there's no dad to discipline
you so I have to do everything so it's
just easier to keep everything
discipline mode so hard yeah that's
tough because it's usually good good cop
bad cop right but then if it's like if
you have to be just cop then it just
ends up being well I'm just gonna be
hard ass all the time yeah and then my
but the fact that my mom could reveal
that now
pretty cool I feel like it's probably
what happened with Joe's moments like 10
years ago but I'm still in the phase of
yes Queen so I'm like yeah you were you
were a piece of [__] actually so I don't
feel like I need a in in your face I
like Yas Queen Bart
yeah
my son is in his yes Queen
she's making me pay for it yeah
you could take steps forward yeah and
there's like that's a big deal there's
no wall because then it's like all right
[__] you're gonna stop being a [__]
let's go
let's hang out more just
this video to go
foreign